la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines agit
quotidiennement au service des habitants
des entreprises et de leurs salariés
dans un esprit de développement durable
pourquoi comment on lâche sa
télécommande on s'installe bien dans son
fauteuil
c'est parti
du lever au coucher les saint quentinois
profil des services de la communauté
d'agglomération dont les champs de
compétences et les missions sont vastes
et là vous voulez en savoir plus et vous
avez bien raison parmi les principales
missions de service public de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et bien
évidemment l'aménagement du territoire
de l'agglomération
c'est à dire la réalisation des réseaux
d'eau d'assainissement l'aménagement des
espaces publics la visage mans espaces
verts mais aussi la réalisation des
équipements publics équipant scolaire
gymnase équipements culturels
nous réalisons les infrastructures de
transport nécessaires les gares les
réseaux de transport en commun en site
propre
et puis bien entendu
nous organisons les transports publics
de 50 ans milite en ce qui concerne les
entreprises
nous avons pour mission de les
accueillir les aider à s'implanter sur
le territoire de l'agglomération mais
également nous aidons les chefs
d'entreprise à créer leur entreprise au
territoire de l'agglomération
nous intervenons également en matière
développement universitaire on est dans
l'université a implanté ces
établissements sur notre territoire
en ce qui concerne les services qui sont
rendus directement aux habitants et bien
entendu
les services culturels à travers le
réseau des médiathèques et ça le
spectacle
nous intervenons pour accompagner mon
emploi en visionnant domaines en
particulier à travers les actions de la
maison d'emploi en matière de santé il y
a l'action de l'institut de promotion de
la santé
enfin dans le domaine de l'habitat la
communauté d'agglomération agi pour
offrir du logement pour tous sur le
territoire de 50 minutes et concernant
l'habitat justement c'est dans un souci
et 3 d'équilibré territorial et de
développement durable que la casse qui
mènent ces grands projets d'aménagement
en lien avec la construction de nouveaux
logements
la desserte en transports en commun et
l'offre existante en équipement
amélioration des performances
énergétiques des bâtiments mixité
sociale action en faveur du parcours
résidentiel
autant de choix qui permettent aux
habitants de bien vivre à saint quentin
en yvelines
à l'image de sophie dar hi han qui
viendra pas dans le cadre des opérations
de rénovation urbaine la casse qui a
vendu à la société hlm et phyllis un
terrain destiné à la réalisation d'un
programme de 17 logements locatifs
sociaux regroupés en quatre villas
urbaines
une proposition a été faite dans leur
logement
j'étais dans un bâtiment qui a été
démoli ont marre loger ailleurs dans un
bâtiment convenable une résidence assez
correcte et on m'a proposé après devenir
un bégaiement nouveaux logements et
dayan ils ont des enfants une petite
famille nombreuse bas où on a attendu ce
projet on a attendu qu'ils sortent et
voila voila un petit bout de terrain un
appartement un peu plus grands sont
sortis de terre l'an dernier fin d'année
j'ai emménagé en décembre les enfants
fréquentent les médiathèques et
randonnée qui sont collégiens donc il
n'a une pas très loin il ya celle de 50
ans aussi où il allait avant pas mal
maintenant répond à celle d'anatole
france qu'on a un côté les arrêts de bus
sont pas très loin on sort de la
résidence son ton sur les arrêts de bus
on n'a pas de soucis on le trouve assez
bien disposés les pièces sont
relativement ou bien disposer au voyage
un peu plus ici que dans un bâtiment le
bout de jardin on en a profité tout
l'été barbecue que vous avez vu lyon
c'est très très bien aménagé on vit
mieux mais pour vivre mieux va sans dire
que l'emploi est une donnée essentielle
c'est pourquoi parmi les dispositifs mis
en place par la case qui la maison de
l'emploi et la cité des métiers
occupe-t-elle aussi une place
d'importance
la cité des métiers déjà c'est très
important qu'on soit salarié ou pas
c'est une source d'information énorme et
les ateliers nous apporte ce qui se
passe sur marché du travail actuellement
la l'atelier porté sur comment
convaincre en entretien et les codes ont
changé
donc il est bon de les renouveler et de
s'imprégner de ces codes pour avoir un
meilleur entretien possible et décrocher
le job
si vous n'avez pas le moral vous venez
ce que déjà voilà l'accueil est très
chaleureux et également c'est ça nous
donne un petit détail une petite
information en plus un atelier qu'on
peut faire et évoluer en tous les cas ne
pas rester inactifs ou des privés dans
son coin comme on peut le faire quand on
cherche un emploi et qu'on trouve pas
les séances publiques la qualité des
services publics à saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est le premier facteur d'attractivité
de notre territoire c'est bien sûr si le
bien-être de nos habitants de nos
salariés
l'argent public bien gérée comme à saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est d'abord de la dépense ou service
de l'emploi les services à la personne
dans le bâtiment
c'est donc un facteur très important de
croissance pour notre pays aujourd'hui
et oui le développement durable c'est
aussi assurer le bien-être des habitants
dans les différents aspects de leur vie
quotidienne mais c'est également
s'occuper des personnes en perte
d'autonomie ou se pencher sur des
solutions d'avenir pour la cité de
demain comme nous allons le voir dans
nos actus du mois
et non début de ses actus avec une
rencontre programmée au musée de la
ville avec l'architecte michel auvin
afin de découvrir des solutions d'avenir
concernant la ville durable en termes de
mixité de convivialité ou encore de
transport en commun les directions
maintenant le maire hanter à magny les
hameaux où j'ai un handicap pilote un
projet financé par trois caisses de
prévoyance de malakoff médéric est
accompagné par la direction des espaces
verts de la casse qui il s'agit d'un
jardin pédagogique destiné aux personnes
en situation de handicap psychique ou
mentale accompagné par l'accueil de jour
handicap
ici on renoue avec la terre on se détend
on intègre des notions de plaisir et des
repères temporels et on passe du jardin
à la maison puisque grâce aux résultats
de la thermographie aérienne menée par
la communauté d'agglomération l' agence
locale de l'énergie et du climat de 50
ans divine peux vous dire si votre
logement est bien isolé rendez vous le 6
octobre à l'espace saint quentin les 18
et 19 octobre à la maison de
l'environnement et tous les jours à la
lèque et pour finir zoom sur le système
bicycode mise en place par la fédération
française des usagers de la bicyclette
il s'agit des graves et une série de
chiffres sur votre vélo et de référencer
vos coordonnées afin de vous permettre
de le récupérer en cas de perte ou de
vol
120 vélos de saint quentinois issus des
sept communes ont ainsi été gravés
gratuitement depuis le 1er avril au
poste de police de guyancourt retient
que vous pouvez retrouver le cahier bien
vivre du petit quentin du mois d'octobre
ainsi qu'une interview du chanteur
sanseverino et un article sur les liens
entre sport et si on sort que pour le
retrouve tous nos rendez vous culturel
du moment
non